c'est retour dansun smartphone que
j'adore c'est le smartphone de gaming
par excellence on se parle ici du rock
Phone 8 Pro d'Asus c'est un modèle qui
est très intéressant et pourquoi au-delà
de tout ce qu'apporte ce smartphone qui
était vraiment déjà génial avec les
générations précédentes Asus est
vraiment venu bosser son bloc photo qui
globalement il faut se le dire de vous à
moi avant était pas terrible première
chose c'est le design Azus est forcément
venu un peu améliorer recorriger et
faire évoluer son design ça reste en
gros bloc 25 g ici il est par contre un
peu plus fin 8,9 mm il est 15 % plus fin
par rapport à la génération précédente
un autre élément sur lequel est venu
travailler Asus c'est au niveau de son
écran principal l'écran est d'excellente
qualité je vous en parle dans quelques
instants mais en fait ce qu'on avait
avant c'est qu'on avait une grosse barre
en haut et en bas pour que lorsque vous
veniez jouer directement à vos jeux et
bien la caméra le bloc caméra selfie
bien évidemment à l'avant ne viennent
pas vous déranger bien Azu s dit ok on a
eu le retour des consommateurs le retour
des médias on a eu pas mal de retour il
faut venir corriger ça ils l'ont fait
d'un point de vue logiciel et je dois
reconnaître que c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal au niveau de l'encoche avant de
la caméra alors par défaut si vous
choisissez le mode que Asus vous propose
et bien c'est un mode noir donc la
caméra elle disparaît mais lorsque vous
jouez en jeu et bien votre caméra le
petit poinon vous allez venir le
retrouver et bien ça fait un truc qui
est pas mal c'est-à-dire que sur tout ce
qui va être applicatif un petit peu
classique si vous êtes pas en mode noir
et bien vous le verrez en mode noir vous
le verrez pas et bien vous allez vous
retrouver avec le petit trou le petit
poinçon dans votre écran de façon un peu
classique mais lorsque vous venez jouer
à des jeux et bien ça disparaîtra parce
que vous avez le mode masqué l'encoche
de la camérare grosse qualité qu'à ce
smartphone au-delà du design que je
trouve vraiment extrêmement sympa et
j'aime bien très très bien retravailler
ici de la part de Asus et bien c'est
qu'au dos du smartphone vous allez avoir
un écran que globalement vous n'allez
pas voir vous avez ici
341 mini LED c'est ce qu'on appellera
l'active vision qui permettra de venir
personnaliser l'expérience de venir
afficher énormément de choses et
d'apporter un peu plus cette patte un
peu de gaming qui est propre à Asus ici
alors regardez vous venez dans les
paramètres pour venir l'activer vous
allez dans Armory crate et la première
chose que vous allez avoir c'est le son
que vous prenez littéralement en pleine
gueule je fais une petite parenthèse ici
parce que sur le rock phone c'est un
truc qui me bluffe depuis des années an
ils ont un son stéréo qui est magnifique
ils ont une spacialisation qui est
vraiment incroyable lorsque vous avez le
smartphone devant vous comme ça et vous
commencez à jouer à l'ouvrir à écouter
un film à venir faire ce que vous voulez
vraiment mais vraiment littéralement
vous en prenez plein les oreilles on
peut demander à Léo qui est juste là en
train de filmer il connaissait pas le
smartphone je lui ai montré tout à
l'heure c'est bien ou pas le son est
dingue le son est dingue toi tu as plus
Doig ouais ouais et donc pour venir
ensuite vous allez dans console la VO
est juste là regardez je mettre à la
verticale vous verrez mieux et dans
console vous avez la partie anim vision
qu'il faut venir activer que vous avez
juste là et là vous voyez directement ce
qui se passe sur votre écran anim vision
avec le la partie ROG avec l'UR et C et
ça et vous avez dans plus de paramètres
et là c'est là que la magie opère parce
que vous pouvez l'avoir lorsque vous
écoutez de la musique également sur les
appels entrant vous avez les
notifications avec les emails le
pourcentage de batterie lorsque elle est
en charge comme ça vous le posez à plat
vous voyez le pourcentage qui monte
c'est vraiment génial vous l'avez écran
allumé vous l'avez écran éteint vous
l'avez aussi au niveau de la caméra vous
l'avez bien évidemment lorsque vous
jouez et ça pour moi c'est un truc qui
est super intéressant parce que ça vient
pousser plus loin l'expérience de gaming
en nombre de pixels derrière c'est pas
fou vous avez 254 pixels par 128 me
direz-vous certes c'est juste un petit
affichage je dirais pour apporter
quelque chose en plus et ce qui est
génial c'est que lorsque vous le tenez à
la main comme ça bien on se rend pas
compte qu'on va vooir un écran avec de
la mini LED la particularité on est en
plein soleil on a Santa Barbara en
Californie et en Californie le soleil il
cogne vous verrez que votre affichage à
l'arrière vous allez pas vraiment le
voir en plein soleil il va pas ressortir
on devine quelque chose mais on voit pas
réellement pour le voir et bien regardez
je vais passer devant ça crée une zone
d'ombre et là ça ressort tout de suite
davantage donc lorsque vous avez des
journées pluvieuses vous êtes chez vous
à l'intérieur au bureau à l'école à la
fac où vous voulez ça ressort mais si
vous comptez sur le fait de bien le voir
lorsque vous êtes en terrasse en soleil
avec des potes et vous la pétez c'est
c'est un peu mort on le voit pas fara
qu'on parle un peu de cet écran
maintenant parce que dans le gaming bien
évidemment un élément qui est
extrêmement important c'est l'écran et
si vous avez un superbe écran de
6,78 pouces c'est une dalle Samsung
c'est un écran AMOLED E6 et qui est
juste merveilleusement bien calibré
alors le gros point fort de cet écran
déjà c'est que vous avez un pic de
luminosité qui va jusqu'à 2500 Nitz ce
qui est assez Dingo c'est queavec cette
luminosité et bien regardez même en
plein jour comme ça vous voyez
extrêmement bien alors là je vous le
montre sur le thème sombre mais si je
vous mets sur le thème clair ça va être
encore pire j'enlève le mode sombre et
là vous en prenez vraiment plein les
mirettes donc c'est quand même vachement
impressionnant alors attention et je
vous le dis vous le savez ça c'est
logique mais je vous le redis quand même
si vous venez pousser la luminosité à
fond comme ça jusqu'à 2500 n max c'est
le pic hein vraiment attention et bien
moment l'autonomie va venir fondre comme
neige au soleil c'est pas forcément ce
qu'on souhaite mais le le la pros qui
est fait ici et qui est vraiment
intéressant avec cette dalle c est
Samsung vous allez réussir à pouvoir
venir voir votre contenu sans aucun
problème et venir jouer très facilement
en plein soleil et ça c'est cool pour
gaming bien évidemment on a ce qu'il y a
de mieux ici avec un écran qui a un tau
de rafraîchissement variable c'est une
dalle ltpo de 1 à 120 Hz alors si vous
le savez c'est déjà le cas l'année
dernière on peut monter jusqu'à 165 Hz
en taux de rafraîchissement vous allez
le faire manuellement ça va pas être
dynamique ça va pas venir se faire
automatiquement le côté un peu
automatique c'est de 1 à 120 vous pouvez
pousser le 265 Hz bien évidemment une
fois de plus attention plus vous montez
haut et plus l'autonomie descendra ici
mais en terme d'expérience c'est très
bien et ce qui est vraiment aussi génial
ici c'est le taux d'échantillonnage
tactile qu'on retrouve sur ce smartphone
on va jusqu'à 720 Hz c'est pas nouveau
mais une fois de plus c'est très
efficace il y a plein de techno que nous
met Asus ici d'un point de vue purement
logiciel pour venir prendre soin de vos
yeux et ça c'est extrêmement important
vous venez bien évidemment une fois de
plus dans votre affichage et dans votre
affichage vous allez avoir
l'entiintimement à faible luminosité ce
qui va faire qu'en fait et vous vous
allez pas vous en rendre compte ce qui
fait que lorsque vous baissez la
luminosité de votre smartphone que vous
êtes dans un environnement plus sombre
notamment le soir lorsque vous allez
venir jouer ou pourquoi pas regarder des
films et des séries et bien vous vous
flinguez pas les yeux donc ça c'est
vraiment un truc à venir cocher vous
avez également l'écran intelligent qu'on
vous conseille de venir activer ici fais
qu'on reparle un peu audio parce que ça
c'est vraiment le truc qui me bluffe sur
ce smartphone depuis plusieurs
générations ici il faut savoir que Asus
bosse avec Dirac vous allez avoir la
technologie Dirac virtuo à l'intérieur
de ce smartphone et quand je vous dis
qu'il y a de la spécialisation et que
c'est extrêmement immersif c'est pas
pour déconner on a du IR audio également
du du iras audio wireless de la PTX
llessess et de la PTX adaptative sans
oublier qu'il a un truc qui est
extrêmement important ici directement
chez Asus et bien c'est que sur Rock
phone il vous conserve la prise jack et
sur un smartphone aujourd'hui à un peu
plus de 1000 balles et je vous donne les
tarifs précis un peu plus loin dans la
vidéo et bien je crois que ça n'existe
pas si si peut-être chez Sony ce qui
reste exceptionnel donc si vous voulez
un smartphone extrêmement complet qui je
vous le dis une fois de plus d'un point
de vue audio qui viendra réellement vous
bluffer et bien ce qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui avec le rockphone 8 Pro même
le 8 c'est totalement bluffant
totalement et je pèse mes mot point de
vue performance vous avez un truc de fou
à l'intérieur le processeur le plus
performant de Qualcom c'est le
Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 qu'on retrouve ici et
qui est juste absolument fou furieux en
plus techno de RAM vous avez de la
lpddr5x qui va très bien vous avez so 16
soit 24 Go de RAM c'est sur une version
un peu spéciale le 24 Go de RAM et en
terme de stockage vous avez de l'UFS 4.0
qui est aussi une super techno soit en
512 soit sur la version limitée en 1
Terra expérience logiciel que nous
propose Asus avec Amor Cry qui est
absolument dingue vous avez le mode
dynamique et voyez très équilibré ici
soit un mode durable on passe très
rapidement c'est pour venir économiser
la batterie ce qui nous branche
réellement c'est le mode X vous allez
venir pousser la performance à fond vous
allez aller très très loin au niveau de
la réactivité tactile l'autonomie va
baisser drastiquement mais pour tout le
reste c'est juste absolument
incroyablece qu'on se parle ici d'un
smartphone qui est un peu plus compact
il a fallu gagner en place à
l'intérieurus a dû venir faire des choix
par rapport à ce qu'ils allaient mettre
dans leur smartphone ils ont donc fait
le choix de diminuer la taille de la
batterie on passe d'une batterie de 6000
mamph l'année dernière à une batterie de
55 100 mamph cette année qui va être
intéressant malgré tout c'est que comme
on est sur un processeur qui va être
bien meilleur au niveau de la gestion de
l'autonomie ce qui fait qu'ici autonomie
va pas venir changer donc ça c'est quand
même un point qui est extrêmement
important attention je vous le Red une
fois de plus comme vous êtes sur un
smartphone de gaming si on envoie du mod
x si on vient jouer en plein soleil
comme ça et si vous tartinz à Max avec
des jeux 165 Hz vous avez beau avoir un
Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 derrière l'automobile
elle va descendre si par contre vous
faites gaffe si vous y allez doucement
si vous jouez 120 Hz si vous vous
branchez régulièrement vous allez venir
pousser l' expéence et il y aura aucun
problème et globalement comme elle est
là l'autonomie est bonne alors après
juste pour info petite batterie
bicellulaire c'est pas nouveau ça marche
bien et c'est cool il faut savoir qu'en
plus ici Asus vous fournit le bloc de
charge 65 W ce qui vient vous le
recharger dans 0 à 100 % en 39 minutes
et en plus de ça vous avez de la
recharge Q8 sans fil et ça aussi c'est
bien la dissipation thermique c'est un
point qui est extrêmement important
également sur les smartphones et
notamment les smartphones de gaming
d'ailleurs toujours plus sur les
smartphone de gaming bien évidemment on
s'en doutera Azus est venu travailler
ici pour éviter que vous ayez un
smartphone qui chauffe au bout du doigt
et que vous puissiez faire cuire un œuf
dessus non ça c'est pas le but soyez
tranquille ils sont venus travailler un
design par couche alors je vous le donne
parce qu'il y a plein de trucs
techniques et je vous le dis directement
vous avez dû une déjà un ventilateur
extate que vous allez pouvoir venir
pluguer directement dessus à voir s'il
vous intéresse ou pas sur la version pro
c'est en option vous pouvez venir
l'acheter en supplément et vous aurez
les T dans quelques instants vous allez
également avoir du graphite vous allez
également avoir du boron nitride
attention là on rentre vraiment dans la
composition très technique qui va venir
jouer bien évidemment sur la dissipation
de la chaleur une chambre à vapeur et
puis surtout vous avez ce qu' appelle le
rapide cooling conductor qui permettra
d'accélérer la dissipation thermique de
20 % là où est vraiment venu travailler
Azus c'est sur toute la partie photo
vous sayz vous avez trois éléments photo
le principal ici c'est un capteur de 50
mégapixel c'est la caméra de Sony c'est
l'IMX 890 stabilisation sur 6 axes c'est
un gimball en fait c'est complètement
fou vous allez voir qu' vous permettra
de faire un X de en venant croper
directement dans le capteur vous allez
également avoir un ultra grand angle
avec une Lenti freeform qui évite la
distorsion qui va jusqu'à 120° puis vous
avez un téléobjectif de 32 mégapixel
avec un zoom optique x 3 un zoom x 5 L
zoom on perd pas en qualité qui permet
d'aller jusqu'à un X 10 en hyper clarity
et on va jusqu'à un X 30 au max alors on
verra bien évidemment on a une
stabilisation optique ici et grâce à la
technologie Pixel binding vous AZ
grouperper plusieurs pixels pour faire
un seul et même gros pixel et capter
plus de luminosité et bien ça vous fera
un équivalent de 8 mégapixels sur votre
téléobjectif et à l'avant juste là on va
retrouver une caméra de selfie de 32
mégapixel avec la technologie RGB W W
pour le White c'est beau alors regardez
les photos là on est sur un joli vélo
bleu alors grand angle on vient se
rapprocher on vient zoomer dedans va
regarder un peu le détail je vais vous
montrer un peu directement vous allez
voir là au niveau de la maison alors
déjà le truc que je commence à à à
trouver c'est je trouve que bien que
Asus soit venu améliorer sa partie photo
elle est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
attend un smartphone à ce tarif là et de
ce qu'on retrouve à la concurrence à ce
tarif là alors attention ici on est sur
un smartphone de gaming ce qui n'est pas
le cas ailleurs mais si vous venez
comparer smartphone à 1000 balles versus
j'en sais rien moi on peut prendre un
Honor un Magic 5 Pro par rapport à ce
qu'on a là on voit qu'on est quand même
assez loin au niveau du rendu photo
c'est quand même mieux que ce qu'on
avait la génération précédente mais
c'est très très très très loin d'être
parfait voyez au niveau des flous c'est
pas parfait là il me mange au niveau des
lunettes il y a y a un truc qui est
bizarre quoi voilà il y a plein de trucs
comme ça qu'on va PIR venir voir à
droite à gauche c'est mieux c'est loin
d'être parfait et il y a très
honnêtement encore un peu de taf contre
jour sinon bon HDR marche quand même
plutôt pas mal là c'est pareil bon c'est
pas trop mal mais des fois j'ai
l'impression de regarder les photos sur
un smartphone à à 300 500 balles et pas
sur un smartphone à 1000 balles caméra
de selfie aussi bon pas mauvais c'est
pas mauvais mais voyez sur le reste là
au niveau des détails au niveau de la
gestion des contrastes au niveau de la
gestion des couleurs il me manque des
choses et je trouve que c'est quand même
assez déceptif c'est mieux mais c'est
pas parfait voyez là c'est pareil là
pareil contre jourbon il sont sort mais
il y a plein de trucs qui font que c'est
c'est pas terrible là c'est pareil je
trouve que la photo est très plate vous
voyez au niveau des contrastes il y a
pas grandchose qui ressort c'est un peu
dommage et ça une fois plus sur un
smartphone à 1000 balles c'est c'est pas
ce qu'on attend quoi là pareil là on
vient zoomer pour choper les oiseaux
mais alors je RTE même pas l'histoire là
c'est pas ouf là c'est un peu la même
chose et voyez c'est un peu l'idée qui
ressort alors la nuit on va retrouver
ces petits allo autour des des zones de
lumière bon voilà ça reste quelque chose
qui pour moi en tout cas au niveau de la
photo aujourd'hui il y a encore un peu
de travail autre nouveauté pas des
moindes votre smartphone est certifié
IP68 résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
ça c'est un truc qui était attendu
depuis très longtemps et assez normal
sur un smartphone très haut de gamme qui
soit dédié au gaming ou pas et l'autre
chose qui est vraiment j'ai génial qui
rajoute en tout cas une brique à
l'intérêt qu'on va voir sur ce
smartphone c'est l'Aero active coouleur
X qui est rangé dans cette étuie et
l'aeroactive couleur X il est pas de
série come on pourrait le dire sur les
voitures c'est vous l'avez pas en fait
sur tous les modèles on va voir sur le
modèle le plus haut mais surtout ce qui
est vraiment génial avec ce petit
élément qu'on va avoir en plus et bien
c'est qu'il vous permet de venir
refroidir et faire diminuer la
température sur le smartphone on voit
bien qu'on a le ventilateur ici au dos
et le truc qui est cool c'est que vous
avez effectivement ces deux boutons de
gâchette ce qui fait que lorsque
regardez j'appuie là il vient se lever
je prends mon smart one je viens le
positionner à l'intérieur comme ça je
referme donc là comme ça il est sécurisé
ça bouge pas et bien ce qu'on voit c'est
que ça va venir vraiment refroid dire
cette partie au dos du smartphone j'ai
effectivement en plus ce petit trépied
que je viens lever ce qui me permet de
le poser à plat ça c'est quand même très
très cool mais deux boutons si bien que
lorsque je suis en train de jouer voyez
j'ai accès à mes deux boutons derrière
mes deux gâchettes lorsque je suis comme
ça voyez bon je joue pas mais c'est pour
vous montrer et bien j'ai mes boutons là
jeis me trigger donc en terme de prise
en main ça vachement en fonction des
jeux auquels je vais jouer je vais avoir
les boutons derrière les air trigger et
puis le clou du spectacle c'est ce que
vous allez retrouver juste en bas à
savoir de l'usbc juste ici pour venir se
recharger parce que vous pouvez en plus
venir vous recharger soit par en dessous
ici soit on peut quand même conserver
celui-là pour venir se rechercher donc
vous voyez on a vraiment le choix vous
avez également ici une petite prise
direct pourir brancher un casque si vous
le tenez à la main mais vous avez
celle-là mais vous avez également
l'autre donc on a énormément de
possibilité c'est plutôt assez
intéressant en fait je trouve ça assz
assez marrant et puis une fois de plus
ce qui est bien c'est qu'ils sont venus
vraiment retravailler ce produit
retravailler le design il est quand même
29% plus petit également 10 % plus léger
et puis pour vienir l'enlever vous
appuyez là voyez ça libère la partie du
haut particularité vous avez un petit
bouton là qui correspond au bouton pour
venir l'allumer et pour l'éteintre qui
est situé juste en dessous ici donc hop
ensuite vous déclipsez vous le retirez
et il est libéré ça c'est vraiment le
point qui est important puisque c'est un
smartphone de gaming c'est maintenant le
moment de parler de l'expérience et du
retour en venant jouer avec ce
smartphone pour moi aujourd'hui je vous
le dit très clairement les yeux dans les
yeux je sur tout ce que j'ai pu tester
dans les smartphones de gaming celui-là
il se détache réellement parce que il a
déjà toute cette expérience globale d'un
point de vue logiciel qui est enfin un
smartphone très unique au niveau du
gaming le point qui est extrêmement
important et très très cool et ça
plusieurs génération c'est le fait
d'avoir les air trigger les air triggers
sont des petits boutons que vous avez
sur le dessus qui ne ressortent pas mais
que vous retrouvez vraiment tactile qui
viennent vraiment maximiser l'expérience
donc lorsque vous jouez à des jeux et
bien vous pouvez non seulement avoir les
boutons mais vous avez en plus lesair
trigger qui sont comme des petites
gâachettes sur le dessus si vous
cherchez un smartphone de gaming et si
vous avez un budget enentour des des
1000 € c'est probablement le smartphone
à venir acheter en 2024 côté gaming bien
évidemment on peut pas passer à côté de
l'expérience logicielle une FO plus avec
Armory crate et Armory crate si vous
connaissez les rock Phone et si vous
connaissez d'une façon un peu plus
globale l'expérience gaming de Asus vous
savez que c'est l'endroit où tout se
passe c'est le point central ici j'ai
mon application dans laquelle je vais
venir retrouver les différents jeux qui
sont installés dans mon smartphone donc
là je peux me déplacer dans mes jeux ok
c'est pratique c'est simple c'est joli
surtout après je vais avir des profils
de scénario regardez je vous montre par
exemple je vais venir cliquer ICI sur un
jeu sur la partie du haut je vais
regarder si lorsque je lance le jeu je
suis en mode dynamique je suis en mode
Ultra Durable par exemple pour des jeux
qui nécessitent pas grand-chose voyez en
terme de performance on peut se mettre
en Ultra dururable ça va venir jouer un
peu forcément sur l'autonomie de votre
smartphone en avancé également pour
venir faire mes propres réglages ou
alors au contraire si j'ai un jeu qui a
besoin de beaucoup de performance et
bien je passe sur le mode X et là ça va
tartiner comme un bourrin donc ça c'est
cool et si vous regardez juste en bas et
bien vous voyez je peux avoir un mapage
aussi au niveau de mes air trigger j'ai
tout tout ici mapage des touches les
macros la zone d'affichage et ça c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure à
savoir que soit vous pouvez avoir votre
caméra votre poinçon qui va être juste
en haut et vous allez avoir votre petit
trou he soyons clair ici soit vous dites
non moi je veux pas de ça moi je veux
venir le décaler bien vous allez sur la
partie du bas vous allez sur dé aller et
là vous voyez que paf ça descend ce qui
fait que vous avez rien qui va venir
polluer la zone graphique de votre jeu
je préfère le côté rempli ce qui serait
mieux c'est d'avoir comme ce qu'on
trrouve sur les Red Magic à savoir un
écran au niveau qui vient couvrir la
partie de la caméra c'est pas le cas
mais c'est quand même déjà pas mal et
c'est bien d'avoir le choix ici donc
vous voyez au niveau de votre jeu vous
avez vraiment le choix et je trouve ça
vraiment cool aè ça vous renvoie sur le
site officiel vos enregistrements si
vous voulez enregistrer vos sessions de
jeux et puis je vous montre dans la
partie en bas à droite il est marqué
disponible sont les jeux et ça c'est un
truc qui est vraiment intéressant
pourquoi parce qu'en en fait vous avez
un catalogue qui va se faire par rapport
à la fréquence d'affichage de votre
écran donc là si vous voulez aller sur
des jeux que en 165 Hz c'est possible
vous avez le choix vous cliquez dessus
et vous regardez vous avez vos jeux en
165 Hz si vous voulez 120 Hz vous avez
les jeux en 120 Hz vous avez également
la la sélection ROG gamepad air trigger
et compagnie donc je trouve que une fois
de plus c'est très très bien pensé on
comprend c'est très lisible et puis
après dernière chose et je vous le
montrer également toute la partie
centrale avec la console la zone
d'affichage qu'on va pouvoir venir
modifier également directement voyez en
venant bouger votre doigt plutôt centré
lorsque vous venez le brancher votre
aéroactive color x bien vous allez voir
ça va vous venir vous activer des option
ici conncé il le reconnait directement
et là voyez j'ai mon mode de
refroidissement donc là je vais sur mes
paramètres intelligent frais glacial et
gelé pour qu'il soit gelé il faut qu'il
soit branché donc plus vous allez aller
vous avez compris au niveau de
refroidissement fort et plus ça va venir
consommer commande d'éclairage qu'on
peut venir personnaliser directement au
niveau de votre aéroactive couleur X en
mode X en mode musique en appel entrant
bref il y a vachement d'options et c'est
vraiment ce que j'adore ici chez Asus
c'est qu'ils font pas ça à moitié et que
globalement c'est vraiment vraiment cool
vous avez également le génie du jeu la
personnalisation de l'ordre des
fonctions les paramètres
d'enregistrement bref voilà il y a plein
plein plein de choses qui sont super
cool ici et qu'on vient retrouver dans
Armory creake alors les tarifs qu'en
est-il c'est quand même important quand
on va un beau smartphone savoir combien
il coûte vous avez trois versions vous
avez une version don je vous ai pas
parlé tout à l'heure c'est la version 12
256 sur la version classique sur le rock
Phone 8 c'est pas sur le pro c'est que
sur le rock Phone 8 et bien vous êtes à
99,99 € quiira un peu moins loin bien
évidemment que le rockphone 8 Pro
ensuite on arrive sur le pro avec 16 Go
de RAM et 512 Go de stockage à
1199,99 € de vous à moi vous rajoutez
100 balles alors je sais que c'est quand
même beaucoup d'argent 100 balles mais
quand on est à plus de 1000 balles bon
je pense que ça vaut le coup de pousser
quand même pour se retrouver avec un
smartphone qui ira le plus loin possible
et que personnellement j'adore et puis
vous avez également une une édition
limitée c'est la pro édition limitée
machine de guerre 24 Go de RAM 1 t de
stockage le tarif forcément un peu plus
élevé
1499,90 € 1500 balles c'est un très très
gros budget mais en terme d'expérience
si vous voulez une brute de machine avec
beaucoup de stockage et énormément de
fludité vous pouvez y aller et puis
après vous avez l'Aero active coer X qui
va pas être inclu partout et qui coûte
un peu moins de 100 balles
99,,99 € donc vous voyez les tarifs sont
quand même très très élevés mais de vous
à moi hein ce ce smartphone n'est pas
fait pour tout le monde c'est pas le je
dirais monsieur madame tout le monde qui
aime jouer un petit peu sur son
smartphone qui va venir l'acheter c'est
pas réellement du cojual gamer sur
smartphone on va se dire est-ce qu'il
existe réellement du hardcore gamer sur
smartphone je pense que oui même si on
ira pas aussi loin que sur PC donc ça
sera pas du hardcore hardcore hardcore
mais ça sera quand même du hardcore
gaming sur smartphone pour ça vous avez
une machine qui aujourd'hui fait
réellement sens c'est le rock Phone 8
Pro que je trouve très cool et qui me
convient voilà moi je l'aime beaucoup je
trouve que vraiment Azus a très très
bien bossé et chaque année ils en
rajoutent davantage il viennent corriger
des choses qui n'allaient pas pour se
retrouver avec une expérience qui n'est
pas ultime parce que avec le rockphone 9
pro l'année prochaine ça sera en encore
meilleur mais déjà ce qu'on a là
aujourd'hui en 2024 je peux vous assurer
qui se moque pas de vous le tarif est là
certes mais vous en avez pour votre
argent d'ailleurs dites-moi s'il vous
intéresse est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des rock fun est-ce qu'ils vous ont
intéressé est-ce que vous avez été
satisfait vous marquez tout ça dans les
commentaires perso je suis content ça me
plaît bien puis d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs de vous à moi on passe
beaucoup de temps sur nos écrans et je
vous ai fait une vidéo que je vous mets
juste là aller jeter un œil c'est les
sept erreurs qu'on fait tous et qui vous
défonce les yeux sur vos écrans l'idée
c'est pas de plus y passer de temps
c'est de passer un un temps où on fait
attention à ses yeux allez voir cette
vidéo elle pourrait vous sauver lesux
you